all right uh joining us now fox news
correspondent at large geraldo rivera
fox news national security strategist dr
sebastian gorka
geraldo i know you wrote a great column
today foxnews.com i want to tell you
something
that i don't want to have happen
i don't want a confrontation at our
southern border
because somebody's going to get hurt or
worse at that border
if they make it all the way from mexico
in the caravans building
you you and i have agreed build the wall
it would be good for both sides if it
was up now right now because they
wouldn't be coming
but more importantly the president
already gave the deal you're offering
which is he offered to make the
accommodation for dreamers and democrats
want to use it as a wedge issue
although now john podesta's group is
saying well don't talk about immigration
i think that it is impossible to talk
about the caravan
or illegal aliens or undocumented
immigrants
with two weeks to go before this
white-hot
primary or midterm election coming up it
is absolutely
impossible to be rational and measured
about it
in this context but i have to just say
one quick thing
this is not about ms-13 this is not
about middle easterners
it's not that simple this is about the
wealthy
country on earth existing children
cannot vouch
or jorge ramos could not vouch you don't
know one person in that crowd i would
argue
that's not going to be the vast majority
but what if there's one
but there are five that would be easy it
would be
it would be easy to find ms-13 or the
middle easterners
the problem is that you have these
thousands and thousands of people
desperate to improve their lot in life
and they're coming
to the but they gotta do the great
colossus
what are we gonna do about them no i
mean we really have nothing
not this american people we have we have
a sovereignty and border issue here
we have laws what are are you going to
shoot what are you going to shoot them
sean what are you going to shoot them no
i'm not going to do it
they need to be stopped what are you
going to do just let them in and say
come on in
and never vet them this is what this is
what you have to yeah i think that we
have this is really
beneath you two weeks geraldo
oh
geraldo geraldo i'm an immigrant
okay so this is important to me
as much as it is to you but to write an
article and then to come on sean's show
and say
what are you gonna do and shoot them
that's un-american we don't say stuff
like that because this is not a
dictatorship
you cannot make statements
what is the military carter what they've
done for
for hurricane victims what they do in
support of the police whenever there's
rioting
it's been done for 200 years gerardo
open a history
has identified ms-13 members sarah
carter has identified them
in the caravan the president of
guadalajara
into this country isis members
geraldo the president of guatemala had a
hundred
isis members we need a measure that
includes the regional governments
we need reason we need patients we
they're incapable if they're incapable
of doing it we're going to put the
safety of americans
in the hands of mexico geraldo no no you
cut you cut off the aid to honduras
sebastian cut off the aid to guatemala
you worsen the conditions there that
exist
right now you create thousands and
thousands of more
displaced people nobody has a right to
come to america
nobody nobody has a right to come to
america nobody
no this nobody they come because the job
13
000 unverified people in this country
rush our borders and do nothing that is
insanity
that is a violation of all
against that group that hapless group
i got a break